former president Mike Pence has been
doing the rounds uh mostly to sell his
book and maybe to kind of softly prod at
the possibility of a 2024 presidential
run and he appeared on a Fox news
program called outnumbered the gag
withoutnumbered is that it's for female
hosts and they invite on a man each show
and the man is outnumbered okay that's
the idea
check out so context this interview that
Pence gave is almost as bad as some of
Trump's worst interviews it's it's
really something to see check out how
Dynamic and funny and clever and
charismatic Mike Pence is right off the
bat and of course I'm kidding he's none
of those things hello everyone this is
outnumbered I'm Emily compagno and
joining me today Carly shimkus Martha
McCallum and Ainsley Earhart and we are
honored to have on the former Vice
President of the United States Mike
Pence it is his first time on
outnumbered and sir we are thrilled and
honored to have you here with us today
oh it's great to be here although I I do
feel
outnumbered
you know it's uh it's great to be here
Carly shimkus but I do feel
outnumbered
just Charisma dripping off of this guy
reeking of Charisma and of course we're
all cringing very very hard now there
were some interesting questions posed to
Pence more interesting was was the way
that he answered these questions he was
asked do you want to be the president of
the United States
lot of time so you know I think one of
the first ones I want to ask you is what
is on everyone's mind because this is a
foundation for people understanding you
and your life we often see books come
out from people who are saying I want to
be president of the United States so my
first question is do you want to be
president of the United States
well Martha I would say no more no less
than any other kid that grew up with a
cornfield in his backyard so is that a
yes or a no you know I can tell you the
dream of Public Service animated my
youth as I write about
uh in the book the opportunity I had to
represent my hometown in Congress to be
governor of Indiana and ultimately to
serve as your vice president it's deeply
humbling to me but Karen and I are going
to take time over the holidays you know
we have two in the military so we would
between deployments our our kids have
not all been back in Indiana uh for the
last three years together so we'll take
time to reflect deliberate talk to the
kids and uh we're gonna we're gonna make
a decision about what our next calling
is but I I promise to keep you posted
but when you do that when you yeah
um let me interpret this answer for you
in you know standard Republican speak
and to some degree politicians speak I
don't know if I'd have a shot at winning
right now Martha so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to bring in consultants and
pollsters to figure out do I have a shot
and if I do have a shot I'm gonna
probably try to go for it particularly
if I believe that even in losing it
might raise my profile or somehow be
advantageous to me in some way shape or
form now one of the things that is a
little bit different
is that as a former VP
it's one thing to lose the general
election for President as a former VP
happened to Al Gore for example but to
lose the Republican primary as a former
VP and in particular to run against the
president you served under that's a
little bit different and that I don't I
don't know has that happened in history
I don't know off the top of my head but
it's sort of a different thing in a
different different consideration a
couple other Clips here citing
absolutely no evidence whatsoever
uh he starts talking about how Twitter
and Elon Musk are being targeted by
Biden because of something related to
the hunter Biden story check this out
the suggestion that uh that the
president of the United States is
keeping a close eye
uh on on any element of of the media is
deeply offensive to me it's it's it's
your job in the media to keep a close
eye on elected officials I I lived in
that world for 20 years as a congressman
as a governor and as your vice president
and uh but I do think as you suggest I I
think it may well be uh because uh Elon
Musk who I came to know very well during
the four years of the Trump Pence
Administration
I think it's because he is preparing to
release information finally about the
suppression of the hunter Biden story
so that this is like two layers of stuff
first of all there's no evidence that
anything that's going on has to do with
the hunter Biden story but again if all
you have is a hammer everything looks
like a nail must be related to Hunter
Biden that's number one but the funniest
and honestly the scariest part of this
is Pence saying you know a white house
keeping an eye on the media Trump had a
hit list of media people that he didn't
like Trump wanted to kick people out of
the press room Trump did kick some
people out of The Press Room like Jim
Acosta from CNN briefly although he
eventually went back he says it's
chilling or whatever phraseology he used
for an Administration to be keeping an
eye on the media the Trump
Administration was maybe the modern
Administration most adversarial and
hostile to journalism and to the media
and to a free press it's absolutely
Bonkers now one last clip here
I won't even introduce this one just
listen oh I want to ask you a question
about your faith because we share the
same faith but how do you know
that that is God calling you because
everywhere you go people love you how to
even Democrats love you because you're
just a nice wholesome good person who
does the right thing and uh and you're
honest you're honest but they might not
like your politics but they like who you
are in your character so I I love that
first of all everybody loves you
Democrats love you listen Democrats
don't love them and the Maga people
wanted them killed on January 6th so I
don't know what on Earth Ainsley Earhart
is talking about but I love the question
how do you know that that's God really
speaking to you it's sort of like one of
these things where Bush said he spoke to
God and God told him to invade Iraq and
then uh you know all these stories that
are told I I checked with God and God
said to go ahead and do it or God chose
this word was it maybe just indigestion
and God not really speaking to you I
just absolutely love that how do you
know it really is God speaking to you
and of course the question has its own
internal Logic for those who believe God
speaks to them
or might or speaks to some people
how do you know that that's really God
speaking to you is a very logical
question they never have an actual good
answer but it's it's just so funny to
hear Ainsley Earhart say how do you know
and also just everyone loves you no no
that's not true the Democrats don't love
him and half of the Republicans don't
love him and some of that half wanted
him killed on January 6. unbelievable
stuff and Penn seems to be in the
running for interviews as absurd as
those that we have seen from Donald
Trump will have all these Pence Clips on
our Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show and remember
you've got to be subscribed on YouTube
subscribe to the David packman Show
YouTube channel if you watch the clips
but that subscribe button is enabled hit
that button it is free all you're saying
when you hit subscribe is I affirm the
David packman show you're not paying
anything
you're not committed to anything you're
just saying I affirm this I affirm the
content affirm away hit that subscribe
button we're going to take a quick break
and be back right after this
the science tells us that one of the
best ways to get consistent deep sleep
is lowering your core body temperature
when your body stays cooler at night
you're more comfortable and your sleep
is better our sponsor sleep me is the
home of chili sleep the customizable
climate controlled sleep solutions that
can improve your sleep by keeping you
cooler at night there are three
different chili sleep systems there's
the uler the cube and the new Doc Pro
with double the cooling power all three
systems are water-based temperature
controlled mattress toppers that fit
over your existing mattress to provide
you with your ideal sleep temperature
you can go as cool as 55 degrees you can
go really hot if you want I keep mine at
60 beautiful temperature for me
don't wake up hot and sweaty chilly
sleep keeps me asleep all night it feels
great I didn't know it was possible to
love sleeping even more than I already
did go to sleep.me slash Pacman to learn
more and get 25 off your new chili Sleep
System click the link below to start
staying cool at night